I'm going to begin by
going over briefly the episodes that I didn't get to cover in the last lecture
because we,
uh,
we ran out of time.
Of course I'm not going to go over every single episode in the novel,
otherwise we would be here for the whole year at least.
So,
uh,
but I thought that I,
I'd say a few things about the adventure of the dead body.
Uh,
we have moved from the brightness of the road to the darkness of the episode of
the dead body.
This is another instance where appearances conspire to fool Gnocchi Halter,
although here it is as a Texas seeing artificial,
there is uh,
uh,
we thought artifice without a and he doesn't turn because he doesn't tend to
people with a corpse into characters from the you Valerie Romances.
This is what is unique about this episode.
Reality as it is,
it's strange enough.
So he does not try to turn them into,
into characters.
From that you ought to read romances,
Dokey,
how this reaction is still to,
to attack as he did the monks in the episode leading to the,
uh,
to the fight with the scanner.
This is another episode,
but some religious resonances and we will have a few and we have had some,
uh,
before the episode of the,
the merchants of Toledo for instance,
is,
uh,
one that comes to mind.
Uh,
it has religious resonances because it is a funeral procession and because one
of the men,
the one injured by Don Quixote claims,
uh,
to be an ecclesiastic,
after all is said and done,
it turns out,
is not quite ordained yet.
And so forth.
Sanctuary again fears the police because,
uh,
now a donkey,
hope it has injured a person of some note,
uh,
and uh,
Doki halting may now be excommunicated from the church for having injured
someone even who is,
who is going to become a priest and who's not yet a priest.
Uh,
so he's now,
uh,
not only a fugitive from justice,
but in some ways also a fugitive from the church.
Um,
now this is the episode also,
we're central calls don't be hot day.
The [inaudible] figura which try Jarvis translates,
uh,
as a night of the sorrowful figure.
Uh,
this is in page a one 39,
uh,
which brings us back,
two characters with physical physical defects that I spoke about before.
Uh,
certainly,
uh,
don't be hotels we will see in the quote has some,
marks and physical defects that make him stand out and lead two centuries.
Um,
uh,
calling him that,
when asked by know chaotic why he called him,
uh,
such a name sent you answers,
that because he says,
I have been viewing you by the light of the torch that unfortunate man carried.
And in truth,
your worship makes at present very near the most woeful figure I have ever seen,
which must be occasion either by the fatigue of these combat or,
uh,
by your want of teeth because you remember that he has lost several teeth.
Have you been struck by one of the stones and the shepherds?
Uh,
hit him,
uh,
with,
so this is a part about his physical defect is injuries and,
and uniqueness as a,
as a,
as a physical being,
but at issue is also don Quixote's awareness that he's adventures will be
written or in fact that they are being written.
And Sanchez invention of the amputate has taken place as the text is being
composed.
The text that we read,
this is consonant with the issue of the novel being a working progress,
not a fixed text,
but one that has been made as we read it.
Uh,
this is a very significant passage that I don't think has been remarked on by
uh,
by criticism,
but it's page one 39 two,
one 40 at the bottom of page one 39.
Uh,
uh,
when south central has explained,
just explained that he,
he looks the way he looks for the reasons that I have just given.
And then as a don Quixote replies,
it is oh into,
oh into neither a reply don Quixote,
but the sage who has a charge of writing the history of my achievements as
thought fit.
I should assume a surname as all the nights of all were wont to do.
One called himself the night of the burning sword and other that are the
Unicorn,
this of the damn cells that have the Phoenix and so forth and so on.
So,
uh,
if you read carefully,
you realize that Don Quixote assumes that it is been written as they,
as they go,
which creates a kind of,
uh,
of,
in possibility.
How can it be written as they act?
Are they following a script or is the writing following what they do?
This is left,
uh,
unclear,
but it feeds into all of the meditations that you find in the novel about the
nature of literature and the nature of writing.
Now,
in addition,
in this episode,
death becomes a presence in the novel during the Bra at the,
in Don Quixote was taken for dead,
if you remember.
Uh,
which will happen again,
uh,
in the novel,
the soft almost dead Marty presides over the episode about his tragic love for
Marcella.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this episode highlights that presence of death in the normal death brings an
element of seriousness to this comical episodes.
Uh,
it lurks as a reminder of the character's vulnerability and generally of the
human need to create,
uh,
art,
in the face of certain extinction.
And here,
uh,
I want to bring,
in,
uh,
align,
from two lines,
from a poem by Wallace Stevens,
the great American poet,
uh,
about whom you will hear a little more in today's lecture.
And then,
and the line is death,
mother of beauty within who's booth alum.
We devise our earthly mothers,
meaning death drives,
uh,
humans to create a beauty.
So this is why the presence of death in the Quixote in a general sense is so
important.
Now,
the adventure of the fooling hammers,
uh,
we don't know what a fooling hammer is.
We don't know what it is in Spanish in botanist's,
they don't exist anymore.
This was kind of,
uh,
machinery,
to a spin a war or something that is driven by a hydraulic force,
by a river or a stream going by.
And it makes this awful,
uh,
noise.
Uh,
we continue in the darkness,
but this,
there is a strange noise that frightens the protagonist,
although Don Quixote denies that he's frightened,
uh,
adamantly.
And,
but this element,
this,
this episode has four elements that I want to bring out.
First is the story of,
of goat herd.
This Doral Ba,
uh,
remember Cisa one,
this is this episode,
uh,
this quinto they [inaudible] it's never ending.
Story is told the story about the,
uh,
about the sheep being brought across the river.
A sanctuary is telling the story and he tells me how to please do not interrupt
me and keep track of the number of sheep.
He said,
all right.
So at one point he asked how many sheep?
And you have as I can remember,
but that's the end of the story.
And uh,
don't be healthy.
He's very angry.
Why?
Uh,
and this is where,
because I told you that that was the,
those were the conditions and so forth.
Now this is a story that's very funny.
It's also a love story.
If you,
if you look at intuit,
uh,
between,
these two shepherds,
these two gut hurts.
But,
uh,
you know,
it is also a story that in which the issue of language and reality is,
is underlined.
Because here,
uh,
sanctuary is a demanding,
a kind of literality.
I mean,
literally one sheep,
you say sheep and there is one cheap,
you say ship station of the sheep.
You can't,
you have to use,
you have to count every single one language cannot abstractly say 45 sheep.
He has to say one sheep to sheep,
three sheep for sheep.
This is a very elementary,
a way of conceiving of language.
But this is,
uh,
what,
Cervantes is bringing in that this,
this,
this folk tale sometimes contain very,
uh,
interesting,
elements about,
uh,
the nature of storytelling.
And this is a,
I don't know if you,
if you know any of these such stories,
but I remember in my childhood,
uh,
hearing some of them now,
the second part we have already mentioned,
and it's the,
the fact that,
uh,
sanctuary defecates out of fear.
Of course,
Sankyo goes to the bathroom out of fear.
He tries to hide it from Don Quixote,
but Don Quixote smells it and tells him to please move away,
that he can't stand the smell.
Um,
classics of Literature.
I think I said this at the end of,
of,
of the class,
uh,
after the lecture,
classics of Literature Contain the whole range of human experience,
uh,
including the most humble physical functions.
And,
uh,
this is,
an instance of that.
There are similar episodes in Chaucer,
I'm sure,
as you remember.
And in Dante also in inferno,
they're very,
uh,
eschatological,
episodes in Dante too,
but not as,
uh,
as humble as a,
this a instance where essential cannot contain himself and has to go to the
bathroom.
The other,
uh,
another element is the fact that they don't hold their beat,
sent you over the head,
uh,
in anger.
Uh,
this continues to round off the relationship between these two characters is the
relationship that includes tenderness and imbues anger.
Uh,
and,
and that is very thoroughly,
uh,
developed in the novel.
This is something new,
uh,
that,
in a way this really invented.
And finally what I would like,
I would like to bring out,
uh,
the question of how does central,
now that there is water in the vicinity,
remedies is,
oh,
there must be water around here.
And how can he tell time by the stars?
He knows what time it is by the stars.
Well,
here we learned,
you may remember,
and I,
I've also,
I've always asked you to read for details that central says that he was a
shepherd ones.
Uh,
and hence he learned how to find water for his animals and fresh,
uh,
grass for them.
Uh,
I think the significant thing here is that we begin to learn about Sanchez past
retrospectively.
It's not as if at the beginning they told us all the narrator tells Sandra who
was a shepherd,
this and that and the other.
And then he begins the adventures to begin to learn retrospectively about a
sanctuary,
a activities in the past,
and how he came to be who he is.
Now these are very effective,
effective device to,
uh,
to fill out the character.
Uh,
and I want you to notice it because it would be other instances where we will
find out other things about Saint Joe's a past.
So,
uh,
so his life is filled on the goal,
not,
uh,
not following a conventional chronological progression.
Because what I want to do to take notice of I say narrative technique and now we
get,
those are the episodes that I didn't get to in the last class.
And now we get to the second part of the today's class,
which has to do with these three topics.
Now,
why does Cervantes
and wider say Quixote focus so much on low class types and even criminals?
This is something I've talked about before,
but I will be harping upon again today.
Now we have spoken about Martinez who is a prostitute.
But there are others,
like for instance,
the servant who beats up donkey hotter in the episode about the merchants of
Toledo,
the rowdies,
uh,
who toss sanctuary in the blanket,
undress,
who's been bitten by his master,
but who seems to be a picker?
Oh himself,
the first in keeper who was,
I've called him a retired Pico and the prostitutes or the first in we will need
others.
What a few other such types.
As we talk about the galleys laves episode today,
we will be attempting to answer this question,
why the focus on this,
uh,
kinds of character about the abundance of low class types and outlaws by the
way,
a galley slaves.
I say this because I'm sure that you have never heard of these before.
It's not something that we are familiar with.
Galileo in Spanish.
We're prisoners or,
or legally slaves who were forced to row in the galleys,
be they private or more,
uh,
often owned by the crown.
That is these,
these,
these ships move with sales.
But also with,
uh,
oars on the oars were manned by the Galley.
Slaves were s sat in rows inside and were whipped,
uh,
to a,
to row.
A harder and harder is a terrible kind of punishment.
And I can go in detail about the lengths of the synthesis there and the fact
that most of them didn't come back alive and so forth.
But,
uh,
that's what a galley slave is.
Um,
the closest I think we have is those chain gangs.
And we see occasionally in some states,
uh,
prisoners going around in their striped uniforms and so forth.
Now,
let me anticipate some ideas and reiterate others that I haven't already
mentioned before to give her a context to what I'm going to be saying.
The renaissance is interested in the nature of humankind,
relatively independent of God.
Renaissance thinkers and artists focus on the characters like the wild man,
for instance,
uh,
who are close to nature.
And those reveal there'll belonging to the natural world rather than to the
social world.
The wild man,
it's an individual lost in the woods or in some cave who lives in a state of
nature away from civilization.
In Spanish literature,
the best known example is say he smoothed though the protagonist of life is a
dream.
It played by Pedro.
God,
they don't,
they'll America that I will be mentioning a often during the semester,
you may have heard of it before.
These renaissance thinkers and artists also concentrate on individuals who
willfully become a marginal to society like madmen and criminals.
The underlying idea is that society masks you racists or attenuates fundamental
traits of the human.
That is also,
uh,
an aesthetic reason.
Social individuals are types people,
individuals in society become types.
Uh,
their features had determined by social conventions attached to their station or
trade,
whereas marginal figures are individual in their appearance and behavior.
Don't Quixote and Santo,
we'll meet characters like Diego.
They meet under the man in green in part two,
who lead boring lives because they conform to social norms.
He is a rich Italian group,
uh,
who lives a life of ease in his estate and who lodges the night and his choir
for several days.
And it's very comfortable house on till Don Quixote gets bored.
Doki hotel and the picture of,
uh,
he meets on the other hand are not boring.
They,
they lead lives of adventure.
They are appealing because of their deviations.
Justice.
They are physically attractive because of the deformities that the bear as we
saw,
uh,
in the last class,
of course,
epic heroes,
I'm protagonists of Javari Romances led very interesting lives,
needless to say,
a full of adventures.
But those adventures took place in,
uh,
in this and in a distance and vague past a,
an abstract countries with generic qualities drawn from literary conventions,
whereas the peaker Roseanne Donkey,
hope they live in the present and live in a society that the reader recognizes
as his own.
The clash between the two is at the core of donkey hotel of course.
But the point is that except in his imagination,
uh,
Don Quixote never inhabited a world other than that of Spain in the leg in the
late 16th century,
among people involved in ordinary activities who do not violate the laws of
nature.
No one flies.
For instance,
in the guilty,
uh,
Oprah forms feats that are beyond human,
strength,
uh,
us,
happens in the epic or as happens in the romances of jewelry.
We are about to comment on an episode of where this clash between idealized time
and space meet,
uh,
real time present day Casteel
I refer about,
uh,
to the episode about Mum Reno's a helmet,
in chapter 21 and here's what your handout may be of some use because in the
individual part of a handout,
I have,
uh,
um,
I have there a barber's basin.
I have the depiction of a barbarous basin because no one in this room has ever
seen a barber's Beijing,
even myself,
because they are no longer in use.
Barbara's basin is this device at the Barbara would use,
uh,
and it has an indentation like that to put her on the under the person's,
Chin and for the neck and then wash the beer and the water would fall in it.
Uh,
and uh,
so I want to go,
I wanted you to have it,
uh,
a depiction of that so you will not what we are talking about here,
why San Angelo says,
what a huge head this giant had this.
Of course,
it's a base in like that.
And he would,
you know,
so
there are two important elements in the mammary no helmet,
uh,
episode,
which is one of the most,
uh,
famous and discussed in the Quixote because it brings to the fore the
discussions about the nature of the reel that dominates the discussion among the
characters,
but particularly between Don Quixote and sanctuary as they do here.
The first element has to do with the,
the first element that I want to bring out in this episode has to do with the
oath.
Uh,
Don Quixote made earlier in chapter 10,
which by fulfilling it would close a loop in the plot.
Uh,
upon seeing the barbers basing shining,
he remembers the oath that he made when he discovered that part of his own
helmet had been damaged in the fight with Biz Caner.
So he says that the opportunity now when he sees the,
the,
the basic,
uh,
rice is to fulfill the oath quote about which I swore,
the oath which I swore us,
you know,
he tells sanctuary and page,
uh,
one 53 when he sees the,
the basic,
he said,
this is the opportunity to do,
fulfill that oath that I made don't get hot.
They had sworn the following up,
uh,
after the fact would there be scanner I quilt.
I quote,
I swear by the creator of all things and by all that is contained in the four
Holly evangelists to lead the life of the great markets of mantra when he vowed
to revenge the death of his nephew Valdovinos,
which was not to eat bread on a tablecloth,
nor Salas himself with his wife and other things,
which I wish.
No,
I do not.
Now remember our allow here for expressed until I am fully revenge on him who
had done me this outrage
quote.
Of course the outrage is the damage to the helmet that he can now restore with
the news that uh,
with a new one that approaches and that he plans to appropriate the normal
begins to acquire.
This is the point and inner density and substance by means of these links,
these connections within the plot,
one link to the other,
the oath and the fulfillment of the oath.
Now the second element that I want to bring up has to do of course with the
confusion created by the wet shining basing that looks like a helmet.
Mum Breanna's helmet belongs to the traditional whole long and his various
incarnations as Orlando Roland or learn.
This is the Carolingian cycle of chivalrous that I mentioned in one of my early
lectures.
Mum Helmet is one,
uh,
with a roller Indian literature in boy,
Yara Doe [inaudible] form core Orlando Orlando love play.
Now the [inaudible] Bank kills the Morris Mum Breeno and winds his enchanted
helmet in Ariosto Orlando Furioso whom I have mentioned before.
I will mention several times in the course of the semester.
Disenchanted helmet had been warm from the mortgage King Mum Brino by Donna
Donielle del Monte,
not sucky Pantheist Don Quixote misremembers and Reinaldo [inaudible] Wilson
when he kills the than.
So this is the background of Merinos Helmet,
uh,
in his imagination,
a donkey hold the acts like the Carolingian hero in obtaining the helmet from
the Moorish king.
So mom Breanna's helmet has an incontestable [inaudible] Rick pedigree deep
pedigree,
which makes it all the more ridiculous that it be confused with the barbers
basing.
So you have to have this background to realize,
uh,
the,
the distance between this mum Breanna's helmet,
uh,
and uh,
on the Berbers basing.
This is why I wanted to give you that background,
but there are attenuating circumstances were donkey halters error,
reality,
contingency,
contingency.
I mean,
accidents
conspire to confuse him as in the case of the dead body,
the basing is not being used for what is intended for,
it was intended to,
to do the barber has it on his head to protect his new hat from the rain.
Remember the detail.
He has a new hat and he puts her on to protect it from the rain.
This is the only time by the way in which it rains in the entire hotel.
If you want to know the detail.
Uh,
the only time when it rains it doesn't rain very often still.
By the way,
I still,
it was very dry and uh,
so this is consistent with the real uh,
conditions of the,
of the region.
Yeah.
So it rains,
uh,
and is being used to protect the hat.
So the barber has it on his head.
I said to protect his new,
uh,
his new hat.
The poor Barbara is the victim of this is a mutation of the circumstance.
Uh,
the,
it happens with other things.
Uh,
in Mickey holiday,
us,
you know,
the inn was originally a stable or parts of the inward,
generally a stable.
In the real world,
things are adapted ad hoc for purposes other than those they were made for.
Their essence does not guarantee their usage.
They are in flux.
Remember what Don Quixote said after the episode of the windmills about
mutations,
how things are in a constant state of mutation.
So reality is in a state of flux as his donkey hope they uh,
himself.
Hence he takes the shining barbers based for mom Bruno's helmet.
This episode exemplifies the modern radical doubt about the power of the census
to grasp reality,
which will become a topic of the Baroque,
the period immediately or almost immediately after the renaissance at about,
which I'll be talking a lot later on.
Remember what I said about the critical Tj cliche that the first part of the
Quixote is renaissance and second part is Baroque.
Yeah,
but the topic of the,
our sense is not being able to really just the stern reality is one that is
still with us.
It is a sort of of doubt about the ray of that we find even today in a modern
pawn such as what as Stevens man carrying a thing,
which is the poem that you have on the other side of your handout today.
I bring up this poem because in one or two occasions,
the basin is referred to us.
The thing I think that shines sign,
Jill says,
as of yet lacking ontological and phenomenological specificity,
ontological,
uh,
it's been,
it's not specify a specific,
it's,
it's appearance is phenomenology.
It's not specific.
And so it's called a thing.
And so I always,
when I come to this episode,
think of this poem by Wallace Stevens was seen as being one of my favorite to
my,
if not my favorite poet,
he was an American port 80 79,
1955 who spent all,
all,
all of his life as an executive for an insurance company in Hartford,
Connecticut.
Nevertheless,
he was really one of the major American poets.
So man carrying thin,
the poem must resist the intelligence almost successfully.
Illustration at Brune figure in winter evening resists identity.
The thing he carries resist the most necessity to sense,
accept them.
Then a secondary parts parts not quite perceived of the off bill's whole on
certain particles of the certain solid,
the primary free from doubt,
things floating like the first hundred flakes of snow out of a storm.
We must endure all night out of a storm of secondary things,
horror of thoughts that suddenly a real,
we must endure our thoughts all night.
And the bride abuse stands motionless in cold.
I don't think the bright all views ever,
uh,
stance motions in cold in the hot day.
But I think that this poem brings,
uh,
dramatizes uh,
the uh,
uh,
what is,
happening in this episode with this thing that,
uh,
Don Quixote takes to be a helmet and sank,
knows is a barber's,
uh,
basing.
This is a Cartesian problem since it,
since it was the character who first gave full attention to it.
How do we,
how do we really know the real doubt as the principal of modern philosophy is
present here already in this sense said Avantis takes leave from renaissance
thought and poetics as in many others.
I move doors,
the Baroque,
the basing would be up here.
The basic will reappear and provoke a full fledge discussion in the,
in among various characters about whether it is a basin or a helmet with
amazing,
they're
hilarious parody of a scholastic debate.
The basing is one of those things that the novel focuses on and that I told you
to take notice of in connection with Albert,
his theories of our perspective because the,
the base in the scene,
in the scene,
in the distance,
in the depths.
Uh,
and this is why it is difficult to ascertain what it is.
Now,
the second part of the chapter contains what I called Don Quixote's own chivalry
romance.
But I know if you remember this part,
but you should,
uh,
here we see don't Kihatha in the act of creating a CI Valerie Romance.
Remember,
Santo Asks Him,
uh,
if they should just,
if they shouldn't go and,
and try to gain some notoriety and fame by doing important things.
And then so then,
okay,
hotel,
uh,
launches on this,
narrative about a,
uh,
chivalry romance,
which he,
he creates out of elements drawn from many of these romances.
He has been able to condense from various romance,
the essence of the Chivalry Romance,
the basic story.
This story reveals what he has in his head.
This probe into the mind of a character is also new in fiction here and
elsewhere,
as in the case of Kardinia whom you're going to meet right away.
Uh,
we get intimations of a character's subconscious,
not just of his actions.
This once the case in the epic that you romances of chivalry and even in the
picaresque here we get,
uh,
something about,
don't you hold this to it?
This will happen several times in,
in the novel.
The story of this,
uh,
while Rick Romance is an exercise in narrative,
but we just said Vantis is underlining the conventions of the two.
Valerie Java,
the fact that there is a kind of basic blueprint or structure upon which anyone
can embroider.
This is true by the way of popular forms of narrative like James Bond movies,
of which they keep making more and more and more because the basic blueprint is
there.
And then all you have to do is to make a slight change in,
in,
in one character here.
Uh,
or a slight change in this kind of adventure.
And a,
you have a James Bond.
Uh,
the same was true with the Conan Doyle,
uh,
on and Jello home stories.
And of course as I've mentioned several times with soap or soap opera and which
is always a Latin American soap opera is always uh,
that the poor secretary has an affair with the song of the very rich a boss.
And so did you can go from there.
You know,
she has a baby,
she doesn't have a baby.
And
so Cervantes us with the picaresque.
Uh,
and we're going to discuss it in the following a discussion of the galleys lakes
episode.
So rant.
This is concerned that the conventions of literature,
it's topics droid away from real life that even the new joggers new in relation
to the classics reassert their literariness by deploying this conventions which
turn into predictable systems awareness of this possibility is crucial to the
whole key.
Hope they are to serve Vantis entire work.
How convention obscures the real and shields shields us from it.
How literature quickly,
quickly retreats from two formulas like dosing,
donkey,
Quixote's mind
self reflexivity helps to point out these conventions and to show their
disconnection from reality.
They're being self generated and self contained.
I am reminded here,
I don't know if you've seen the kiss of the spider woman,
but a,
it's a great movie and you remember that Molina is telling his cellmate all of
these movies that he has in his head,
he has memorized and there are people who have memorized the plots of many
movies and can condense them into a kind of a generic movie.
The way don't Quixote is creating here at kind of a generic chivalry romance.
This also plays into the game of mirrors that they can hottie is becoming.
It is a story within the,
the large story is a parody of a romance of chivalry.
It is this what is calling French composers on a Bema,
uh,
and in,
in,
in English is the infinitely receiving sequences that we found in Velasquez
Meninas.
The story within the story,
like the painting within the painting,
like the play within the play in hamlet.
I first visualize this as a child looking at the label on a condensed milk can
and the label depicted a condensed milk can with the same label within which
there was another,
uh,
label with the same condensed milk can and so forth and so on.
And I had the vertigo of not knowing whether I was part of a larger condensed
milk can have some uh,
such depiction or
guys,
they don't go to a barber shops anymore.
I don't know,
think it doesn't look like it to me,
but I mean some of you,
some of you do,
but,
but a little boys discovered this in barbershops when you sat in the barber's
chair and you were surrounded by mirrors and certainly you show yourself,
wow.
Get lost in an infinity of,
of reflections of yourself.
There is an infinity receding sequels
that is,
there is no without,
if you are within that,
you're always,
uh,
everything is within literature,
hearse.
Hence there is no authority that orders the universe of fiction,
which is continuous with that reality.
The only infinite being would be God.
So to posit this kind of,
so to posit this kind of abyss like universe is a form of radical skepticism on
the part of Cervantes,
on of Shakespeare.
By the way,
uh,
here,
the authority within that fiction is house of mirrors.
I'm sure you've also gone to a house of mirrors.
Uh,
uh,
is a madman don Quixote as within the picaresque and we will get to that.
It is,
it will be [inaudible] the PASA mounting.
Another important point about this generic g Valerie Romance,
that donkey hopping,
uh,
comes up with here in answer to Sanchez question,
is that Don Quixote reveals his worries about his lineage.
He is,
he has to acquire fame to aspire to marry a princess behind this.
Apparently ninth preoccupation lays one of the social issues at stake in the
novel,
the question of social class and privilege and the possibility of acquiring it
rather than inheriting it.
Uh,
you remember that he,
he's,
he,
he speaks here about he will acquire enough fame by dint of his own valor to
married being married to a princess.
Uh,
even in the relationship between the night and his choir,
there is there intimations of a leveling of social classes here in this,
in this.
Uh,
and you will see as we move,
we move to part two,
but this will increase the Santos importance in the novel increases.
So this is one of the topics,
but here we get another glimpse at Oakey hold.
The subconscious he is worried about his lack of nobility is lack of
aristocratic background.
Okay,
now we get to the galleys leaves,
uh,
which is again,
another famous episode,
uh,
in the keyhole.
This is chapter 22,
part one,
because it also shows a Cervantes dealing with the question of literature.
Uh,
more specifically the picaresque,
uh,
notice by the way in this,
chapter,
the mistranslation when Jarvis renders renders Alpha witty as pimp.
In page one 66,
what it should be,
go between the galleys slave who has been a go between.
Remember the donkey help,
they actually praises,
uh,
in the,
in the original it says,
[inaudible] is someone who arranges marriages.
I eliciting encounters between lovers and all of that,
but he's not a pimp.
A pimp,
uh,
is,
is an agent for prostitutes,
uh,
alcohol wipe this or go betweens,
have been priced throughout the ages,
even by Saint Augustine.
At some point,
he praises the,
the job that they do in arranging couples to meet and become lovers.
So just,
just the detail about,
about the translation.
Uh,
I don't want to Belabor the failings of the translation,
which is a pretty good one.
Now again,
why the picaresque you want to go?
And you might be getting tired of my talking about the picker rest,
but the picker ask is the new,
uh,
fiction that precedes the keyhole pay precedes the ramp.
This work,
uh,
within which and against which he,
he writes
not only because the picaresque comes up again because not only because,
uh,
like the Picato,
he nest the [inaudible] who is the,
the main character here,
uh,
is a criminal bar.
More importantly,
because he missed the [inaudible] is an author
when asked
if his book is good by Don Quixote,
he nas replies,
I'm on page one 69.
So good answer.
He says that woe be to Las [inaudible] miss.
And to all that have written north shore or shall write in that way on what asks
for the title.
And if it is finished,
he needs answers.
Quote,
if called the life of [inaudible] replied,
he knows himself and is it finished?
Both Don Quixote.
How can it be finished?
Answer,
he says,
my life is not yet finished.
What is written is from the my cradle to the moment of my being said this last
time too.
The galleys.
Oh,
cool.
Ah,
picaresque novels tended to be called [inaudible] life off [inaudible] law.
The life of UNESCO someones day is obviously a picaresque kind of novel that he
has written about himself.
So Cervantes is poking fun here at the conventions of autobiographical writing.
Meaning how can you write an autobiography if you your rice?
It is not over.
It's what,
uh,
what,
he knows answers and surround.
This is spoken in front of that.
Uh,
so which leads in autobiographical writing as in the,
in the confessions of the north,
you know,
so forth to the creation of a death and resurrection kind of a scheme.
That is,
I,
uh,
I'm speaking about the man that I formerly was until I,
I had a conversion by which the old man died on the new one arose and so forth.
So this is what is behind this little repartee here between [inaudible] and
Oakey holiday,
which is,
uh,
a satire of autobiographical writing and of,
an off the picaresque novel,
uh,
specifically,
here,
uh,
he nest on this underscores the fact that there is no way to put a stop to it by
saying that the last time he went to the gallery,
so every time he went to the galleys he takes up the book again and writing and
writing and writes it.
And he says at one point here that he doesn't mind going to the goddess because
there he'll be able to finish this book.
So there is a kind of literal continuity between life and writing.
That is what is being made fun of in this episode.
Now you remember the whole background of the bicker ESCOs are giving it to you
many times from the cell is Deena do the goose Mondale farace f 15,
99.
Right at the time don't be,
I mean Sorento riding donkey hoppy.
I mean there was Mondale for Rachio.
The protagonist is a galley slave at one point.
So the allusion to there was Amanda for Roger here is very clear
now he asked them,
[inaudible] is one of the most important secondary characters in the Quixote.
This is what an oxymoron.
Secondary and important.
They are important secondary characters and Kerrick secondary characters that
are not important.
Not only because it's really fun and we're,
I'm funny,
he's really a lot of fun.
Uh,
and he will be up here,
but because he's one of the story tellers in the book,
hence is part of the books take on literature and the nature of narrative he
knows is one of the many storytellers in the Quixote by mean characters who not
only tell a story or recite a poem,
but who are writing or have written a book.
They both memorable of these are of course the narrator of the Quixote who
claims not to be the author,
the Apocryphal Cdma,
traveling,
Haley,
the translator and so forth.
These are all characters who have written a book.
There'll be all this got Daniel [inaudible] Cervantes is considering with them.
The possibility of new John was new forms of literature emerging,
which they are at the time that he is writing and showing the mechanisms by
which a new Java is born a new job.
I'm meeting a new kind of literature that is not merely derived or copied from
the classics as what's done or attempted to be done in the renaissance.
These are,
uh,
authors like lawpay the Vega who's name I've mentioned many times,
and I'm not going to put it on the board because you must remember who created
as it were,
the Spanish theater,
national theater,
the chameleon.
Uh,
and so he never is as complex a figure as other narrators with hope.
They like,
see,
I made the binning heavy.
Uh,
and I remind you again and I'll good probably again in this lecture that at this
point between the 16th and the 17th century,
the first professional authors are emerging.
That is authors who are trying to make a living from the writing.
Nope.
He did a very,
very well because of course you,
if he wrote so many plays on the word,
they do so well.
Cervantes didn't do so well as we know.
No.
This interest in the nature of literature and the figure of the author in the
Quixote is because the novel,
this novel,
the hotel is not so much about the question of the book as it is about that of
the books in the plural.
As we saw in the episode of the scrutiny of the library.
It is about the proliferation of books made possible by the development of the
printing press and the economic factors that encourage editorial production in
the 16th century.
The Quixote is the first major work to consider how the dissemination of books
on settles received notions about the book and about authorship.
Uh,
this,
uh,
remember again turn of the century 16th to the 17th new John has new authors
like Mattel and [inaudible] who are professionals and so forth.
This is tied to the whole issue of the book.
Thanks.
No,
I'm going to go into a part of a lecture here that might get a little dense
because,
um,
uh,
it's about,
this proliferation of books in relation to the author on the voracity of the
books.
I'll go very slowly,
uh,
because I myself feel that it is a bit dense and I don't want to confuse you.
And if I do,
you raise your hand in protest.
The proliferation of books,
it's accompanied by a decline in social,
in the social class of authors and have the author figures by which I mean
characters like he nest the Pasa Monday who represent authors within the
fixture.
Now take stock of this.
He has a persona is a criminal,
uh,
is a prisoner.
He's a galley slave.
However,
he has written a book.
This is novel.
I mean that someone of his social class couldn't be lower,
is writing a book.
So justice,
the production of many copies of a single book brings down the fetish value of
each single copy as happens with anything.
If you have too many or something,
the value declines.
If you have very few,
the value increases.
I have a $2 bill in my,
with my wallet somebody gave me and I've kept it because they say it's good
luck,
but also because a few of us,
so this is the fetish value of things,
uh,
that are few.
This we've learned in economic classes,
uh,
since we were going to high school.
So,
uh,
but the opposite is true of the authors and author figures relevance,
which increases the value of each copy of his book,
decreases the authors now become the guarantee of the work's worth as well as
the one accountable for it.
Before the law.
In the case of the Commedia,
the Spanish place where proliferation was rampant to be,
they Lopi by Lopi became a sign of excellence,
like,
like a trademark applicable as an indication of value.
Uh,
two things other than place you can say this thing is the Lopez and it meant
that it was very good
in the pickers.
Author and protagonists are conflated into one book and author became become one
as in the case of Hennis,
who's Reductio ad absurdum of this textual strategy has been noted many times.
The one that we just seen.
Um,
and rudimentary equation could perhaps we worked out these new authors break
with the strictures of renaissance.
We Macy's the idea of imitating the classics in the sense that they innovate
leaving behind classical forms and themes or subjecting them to substantial
transformations.
Okay.
There are no longer like the classics.
They are subjecting them to transformations.
Hence the dissent in social status of the author appears to be accompanied by an
increase in inventiveness and rice in the importance of the author.
Is that clear?
It should be clear.
No,
they higher the social class,
the less the invention because they follow me.
Masons,
they imitate the classics.
Um,
the Lord the author Social Class,
the greater the invention,
hence more value attached to the author,
uh,
which leads to the following,
the more invention,
the more value given to the author he to pass a month who prides himself on
written this book about himself.
This explains why I said [inaudible] did before.
This is the place why,
as Allie Mang did before with his Guzman,
the Al Farace,
uh,
Cervantes rushes through,
right?
His second park.
Once he learns that [inaudible] has written a second part of the hope that he
feels that they can hold the,
is his invention,
his and that,
that in,
in,
in every sense,
including the,
the monetary sense that he's going to lose,
uh,
revenues if somebody else writes,
if the whole thing.
So,
so it seems that the impact of the social economic developments on books and
authors is undeniable,
but that is another important,
important factor at work that issues from the content of the book themselves and
its relation to knowledge.
I think.
I hope that you have made that clear.
No,
this is,
uh,
this is clear and [inaudible] exemplifies the lowering of social class.
Cervantes himself was not,
it was a very petty,
noble man,
poor and so forth.
So,
uh,
so [inaudible] important because he exemplifies that drop in social class of the
author.
Now I'm,
Tony Grafton opens the introduction to his magnificent new world's ancient
texts,
the power of tradition and the shock of discovery with these words.
Grafton is a professor at Princeton University.
The book is called New World's ancient texts,
the power of traditional.
And the shock of discovery and according to the following,
it's very important quote.
I want you to follow it closely.
Between 1550
and 1650 campuses,
just the time that wanted
Western thinkers ceased to believe that they could find all important truths in
ancient books,
so whereas the early renaissance thought that all important truths could be in
book.
Now this has decreased
grasp.
Don goes onto court,
Jesuit wholesale.
They are Costa.
Very common name in Spanish.
We'll say the course
who wrote in his,
this is a book about the history of the new world goalie story and how to rally
morale.
De Las Indias.
This is Acosta,
quoted by Grafton.
Having read that,
what poets and philosophers,
right of the torrid zone.
I persuaded myself that when I came to the equator,
he was traveling to the new world.
I would not be able to endure the violent heat,
but it turned out otherwise for when I pass the equator,
I felt so cold that I was forced to go into the sun to warm myself.
What could I do then,
but laugh at Aristotle's meteorology.
Oh,
quote.
Ironically.
Then the proliferation of books begins at the time with the authority of the
book was most severely tested and ultimately devalued.
The ability to read many books did not bring one closer to the truth would do an
inordinate,
perhaps infinite enlargement of the library.
I'm [inaudible].
This is madness or to the Carter's your pants,
don't you?
Sweet.
I think therefore I am.
I only know that I am because I think in this way he discards the whole of the
philosophical tradition in books before it.
These two leads in the direction of an increase in the importance of the officer
just as the classical tradition has been refashioned or denied altogether,
so it's received knowledge from the canonical books being questioned.
The function of books changes not only because the printing press makes them
available in larger quantities,
but also because they are no longer seen as reliable purveyors of truth.
Experience becomes a very important element in thinking in philosophy
literature,
not books.
Eve Acosta in the 1590s can laugh at Aristotle.
Why not pick up there the picaresque novel and have a good laugh or at you
Valerie Romance and be entertained or aroused instead or the key hot there and
have a good time.
Reading books is not equated as before with the acquisition of knowledge but
increasingly with pleasure.
And the value of each book is dependent on an author whose ability to produce
such pleasure is known.
The scrutiny of the library and RTC Laura's dream clearly show some of the
quandaries,
uh,
that this new situation opens up or does your daughter's dream is this marvelous
episode in part two.
When a character you will meet her MLTC Dota has a dream and when she sees some
devil's playing tennis and the balls are books on the racquets are flaming
rackets and when they hit the books,
the book,
uh,
explode and be our polarized.
So maneuvers and dream about what I'm telling you about and you will get to it.
Of course,
the book that is pulverized most easily [inaudible] your apocryphal Quixote.
I said this,
uh,
takes advantage of this episode to poke fun at his,
at his,
uh,
at his rival.
So
this is why,
uh,
he missed that by Samantha is so important.
He Nest [inaudible] who is now,
who now appears,
and I won't have to have the quote here,
but I'm sure you remember how he is shackled.
He is covered with chains from head to foot.
He cannot move his head down to reach his hands,
not have his rants rich,
his mouth it,
it's as if you were percepts of some demonic power.
Slipperiness uh,
here I said,
Rhonda,
this is anticipating kind of a romantic notion of the author as a,
as a,
as a demonic figure.
Uh,
but the most interesting thing is that he needs the Pasa.
Monta is also a self portrait of [inaudible] because at one point,
uh,
he nets describes himself as being very unfortunate.
Uh,
and the line is obviously a itself,
uh,
elusive line on the part of Cervantes.
He,
uh,
he Nessa [inaudible] is a figure of Cervantes in the book lower class and also
this inventiveness that has to be contained by all of these chains that hold
him,
uh,
that holding a dom
in part two.
He will reappear and I can anticipate having a lot of fun with nest when he
appears in part two.
And he is a master puppeteer.
He has a puppet theater.
And I will not ruin the plot by telling you what happens then.
But it's hilarious and it dovetails what I have,
uh,
been telling you about,
here now.
So this slippery slipperiness in the part of this,
uh,
author figure,
is,
is connected to all of these games of authorship.
You know,
the slippers,
the slipperiness of CDMA,
[inaudible],
Haley,
the slippery does have the translator,
uh,
who,
who has the text translated and all of that.
They're all,
they're all uh,
contained within this figure of [inaudible].
This pick a room is bigger,
but there's one more aspect of he nester I want to discuss and that is
containing an essay that you have in the case book,
uh,
about Hennis being crossed height.
And uh,
I am going to simply summarize it because we're coming to the end of the hour
and a direct you to that essay of mine if you want,
uh,
the details.
Do you remember that when he ness is introduced it,
it says behind all these came amount of some 30 years of age of a goodly aspect,
a sub,
he seemed to thrust one I into the other.
What it means is that he knows is crossed eyed Matea walking a lot or we still
say in Spanish.
Now vision of course is tied to representation.
You represent what you see.
And He Naz being an author figure who is cross eyed is very suggestive.
Uh,
first of all because being cross-eyed gifts,
he miss a shifty look when,
uh,
when you say,
but you look at somebody in the eye to see if they're being sincere.
If there's something in the eyes,
it doesn't have to be gross.
I'll be in cross side.
Then the person doesn't appear,
Cynthia,
you know,
so I saw being cross eyed gifts Ynez a shifty appearance going to with a
slipperiness.
Also his generals like that.
If you look at it from one side,
you'll see one eye this way.
If you look at it from the other side,
the other way he's going,
yeah,
he's going the other way.
So He's two things at the same time,
whether you look at him from one side or the other.
So there is no oh center,
no stable figure of [inaudible] because he is girls.
Alright.
He is uh,
he has a monocular cross eyedness that is one eye is the one that goes into the
other.
Uh,
so therefore if you have a two lines of sight that normally meet here in this
object and that object is represented to your mind,
oh well,
if you're cross eyed,
they meet here and therefore the object is distorted.
This is what monocular across eyedness,
uh,
means also it leads,
it leads to uh,
uh,
a double vision that what is called diplopia.
Sorry for this.
Yeah.
So he missed softwares from this cross,
cross eyedness diplopia or double vision.
He sees two things at the same time and he is,
uh,
this figure of the author,
the figure of the author who like the Cervantes or the first prologue who has to
divide himself in two persons,
uh,
is to within his own vision.
Because you know,
this is double.
What I'm trying to say is this,
you will see that one of the topics in the Quixote criticism is perspective,
is that reality is a scene from various perspectives,
the perspective of each one of the characters and that supposedly reality in the
end of some of these hilarious his coaches at the end is the sum total of all of
these perspectives.
What I'm trying to say is that there is no such thing that within each
individual there is already perspective as in because there is more than one
view of things.
I want to emphasize this.
He makes cs two things.
He's not,
you're simply one perspective.
His is him within him,
not just from all the others perspectives.
This complicates the issue a lot more,
but particularly when you take into account that he is presented as an author
figure,
as a storyteller in the chaotic,
uh,
storytellers in that he hoped,
they tend not to be very healthy,
you then physically or mentally and he ness is important,
uh,
because of,
of that.
So we're going to leave it at that.
And the next,
uh,
in the next class,
we're going to talk,
I know about another one of these galley slaves in passing,
the one that I have called in my book love and the law,
the prisoner of sex.
And this is the,
the,
the minor character.
This is a really minor,
minor character.
One paragraph.
If you go back to this episode of the Galley Slaves in 22,
the guy who is carrying on with war for women at the same time to have homework,
cousins of his.
So we are going to be talking about about that and other matters that are in
your,
in your syllabus.
But,
uh,
but I'll begin by talking about the person or have sex.